[Music]
shall we begin
okay relax like you're asleep you're
sleeping you're dreaming of some eight
foot tall demon looking [ __ ]
oh yes a dream I like that
dreams are places you can have fun right
it's all in your mind so why not enjoy
it Shh listen go and check it out
[Music]
now we could in this dream of yours take
care of a situation like this we just
put Kenny's name down and see what
happens
I know you want to go on help her I
don't know 10 15 you go to bed
good now as long as we're playing let's
do it right there's no need to stop it
oh sorry what else is there Wow third
beginner not bad at all now watch all
the people that make life miserable make
life dangerous
what if we can change things
the human whose name is written and
shall die
shall we begin your death god yes what
exactly can I do with this death no put
anything down and see what happens not
gonna solve a few crimes it's gonna
solve all crime do you think that I'm
crazy I think you're not prison enough
we could change the world
the killer has taken credit for over 400
deaths although we do not know how he
kills his victims we do know it's not
some of nificent force he's a perfect
like you or me or the one who flew into
the Sun I'm just here to make sure you
Burt you're not the good guys anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
humor super
but they want
is it gone so let's give it to them
[Music]